[Musique]
non j'ai été pas tout seul
arrête de pleurer comme ça devant tout
le monde parce qu'une demi vieille parce
qu'une fausse blonde par laisser tomber
en chef t'es pas tout seul mais tu sais
que tu me fais honte à sangloter comme
ça bêtement devant tout le monde parce
qu'une trois cas [ __ ] t'as craqué dans
les mains
non j'ai fait pas tout seul mais tu fais
honte d'avoir des gens super peps
foutons quand deux trottoirs
bien bien
via
et le reste aux trois sous on va laisser
les boire j'ai l'âme et françois bien
j'ai bien bien
il ne reste que trois sous ici pas céder
l'escr à la douane
puis on ira manger des moules et puis
des faillites des frites et puis des
moules et du vin de mauvais
les citer encore triste on ira voir les
filles j'ai la même amende
par ailleurs neuf nouvelles
on sera bien tous les deux on chantera
comme un rang comme quand il était jeune
chef comme quand c'était le temps que
j'avais de la motion
jeff t'es pas tout seul
l'arrêt des grimaces soulève t 100 kg
chez brigitte accart gaz du secteur
comme rooney
sans le soulever
t'es pas tout seul ou
barrette de sangloter arrête de tourner
pendant avait de répéter que tu es bon à
de foot à l'eau témoins tous pendent
dans gf t'es pas tout seul mais c'est
plus un trottoir ça devient cinéma où
les gens viennent nous voir bien bien
géré
rien il me reste ma guitare je la lui
murray pour toi et on serait ce
bagnolais viens viens comme quand on
était mômes même que j'aimais pas ça tu
limitera aux signes ans
p on se trouvera un banc on parlera de
l'amérique ou c'est qu'on va l'excusé
quand on aura du free jazz et cite
encore triste pour rien si tu en as
l'air je te raconterai comment tu
deviendras rockefeller
[Applaudissements]
sera bien tous les deux pour chanterac
comme avant comme quand on était beau
geste compte quand c'était le temps
d'avant conçoit poids vont aller vers
elle
bien ouais ouais j'aime way vient chef
bien
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]